I decided we would do one together me
and John Flickinger we do one together
for a shitty terrible movie that I've
seen but he has not yet seen I'm really
not excited at all I don't want to be
here but without further ado maybe we
should just start this piece of shit so
we can cry and laugh and I I don't know
okay just set this up this is one of the
worst reviewed movies of the year it's
my least favorite movie I've seen in the
entirety of this year and we're gonna do
a hilarious 'ti of this but we want to
exclusively give you guys the full uncut
commentary here on patreon so we're
about to watch this on Netflix it is on
Netflix and the timecode is right at the
very beginning and I'm about to press
play in three two one play Netflix logo
yeah you know it's gotta be good that's
what we should do for the whole
commentary just like when something
comes up we just state what it is yeah
the Open House logo
he jerking off what's this he was
running just jogging down the road I
thought maybe he was even though I've
seen this already if this movie was made
like seven years ago this would have
been Logan Lerman or whatever his name
is
that's true Logan Lerman yeah he does
kind of remind me of Logan Lerman I do
like Dylan Minette thought he was great
in prisoners yeah yeah he's uh he's okay
he's got a lot of fans on that 13
reasons well yeah I did watch that I
only watched the first like two episodes
he feel like he plays the same character
in every movie I got I can say that I'm
like a confused teenager and I've been
in the goosebumps gustas my way I played
the same character I couldn't really get
into 13 reasons why me neither and you
watch the whole thing now I did it was a
girl who left these really self-absorbed
video cassette messages about her life
and all the diet Rob's yeah why would
who what girl has tape cassettes yeah no
one I don't know man
so like the whole thing with this movie
like this character like from what I
remember anyway cuz I kind of hated this
movie so like I tried to forget about a
lot of it he just he's like almost gonna
be like an Olympian or some shit like he
wants to be an Olympian Runner and then
so he's just like training and I don't
know we have these intense close-ups of
his eye taking out icon contacts yeah
it's just this is directed by a man and
woman first-time directors and just
every sound is heightened to like 10,000
the contacts the eggs dropping when you
don't have a scary movie just make eggs
dropping loud OH
most of this movie is something like
that actually oh man can't wait noises
just fucking noises
so let me ask you a question okay ask me
a question we have son and father who
have gone out alone somewhere what do
you think is gonna happen
the dads going to go in the kids are
going to stay out the dads probably
going to get robbed as he walks into the
store or out of the store
well this something does happen to him
okay
was I like somebody's friend reminds me
of the room have a nice day had my
favorite customer your hair customer
thanks a lot bye oh hi doggy doggy here
we go I was gonna say I thought he was
gonna get hit by a car but I was like
that's too stupid yeah I mean and that's
literally that's how they edited the in
the car just driving 90 in a parking lot
there's like a parking lot at a gas
station some cars goes around tell us if
that's the best thing they see if the
convenience store got robbed and he died
in the process of that that would that
would have been something would have
happened I would have been good
something different sort of like death
sentence with Kevin Bacon that's how
underrated movie it is I love it
but yeah I mean there's no explanation
they you know they're just sitting in a
gas station parking lot and like you
said a car seems to go from zero to 90
in a second he was killed by a Honda Joe
Cooper driver honestly though like that
kind of looked like murder to me it yeah
there that was definitely some kind of
reckless driving is it like
involuntary manslaughter yeah yeah yeah
like I still don't think the car that
car had it was like a compact I don't
think I had the horsepower the
horsepower the weight to kill him maybe
a broken leg or two
[Music]
the majority of this movie is shot and
lit just fine but almost the entire film
is just like shot reverse shot over and
over again the most basic angles and
cutting it it it doesn't look filmic to
me it looks very tv-show esque yeah it
does
it looks very digital it does yeah a
little bit over lit mm-hmm his name is
even Logan yeah it is Wow
some nice plants in their back every
buddy could sell those make ends meet
maybe they maybe they do sell plants
maybe they sell drugs yeah that could be
they sell drugs to people that the
person who killed the dad was someone
who got some shitty drugs this is a
pizza delivery driver so he killed them
but yeah like that whole scene right
there yeah with this random woman is
just to set up the fact that there's an
open house somewhere that they can go
and stay at for a while I guess to get
out of the house to give it to well she
doesn't have any money suppose the
leaves so now they yeah I'm not sure
what they're doing actually did they
sell their house or they you know I've
seen the movie and I don't know for rent
for rent oh they had to rent the house
okay but like that from what I remember
that girl never shows up again she's
just there to be like hey I got this
house you should go to the house yeah
and then it just gets the characters to
this creepy house somewhere that's all
it does there's everyone's just a plot
device
it's very contrived it's there's no
rhyme or reason for what's happening
right now it's just one thing and then
the next thing but they don't really
make sense combined I just like how like
their dad just got killed in a parking
lot and it's like it never even happened
they're just it's just like hey hey how
can we get them to go to this house
well we'll kill his dad on a parking lot
and they'll have a random
friend who has the house that's it
everything's just a plot - how
convenient right yeah still upset about
the car that killed the dad I just that
was that's the worst part of this movie
it was the cheapest edit just hmm
in Dillon minutes face girl I wish you
would add a kazoo min SH out of the
dad's face screaming with headlights
perfect yeah I wish they would have
shown the impact like a final
destination yeah are like bye-bye man oh
yes bodies where it hits the tree it's
the best scene ever made
Wyatt why is her phone on the floor hey
I'm just gonna put my phone on the
floorboard for the trip between your
legs there's just a guy in the road why
would he not be okay you didn't are lay
that way your father died so like I
guess that's the killer
yeah just wearing his overalls in the
middle of the road let me ask you a
question yes please if you were a
sadistic killer yes why would you stand
in the middle of the road when an
oncoming car is like approaching you
yeah what if that car just didn't have
great reflexes see yeah and my question
is how long has he been standing and
standing there yeah it's not like he
knew they were coming yeah yeah did he
just fucking wait there all night
waiting for them to fucking drive up
just waiting in the fucking road for
that one car that conveniently might
just be staying at the house I'm gonna
maybe kill them in it's funny because
like you know okay so guys we're gonna
get into a few little spoilers here and
there but like III won't ruin anything
for you if you really want to know
what's gonna happen but like once you
once you know the ending nothing makes
sense you know like once you understand
what's happening or actually even you
don't know the ending nothing makes
sense yeah but like the lack of
understanding even that comes with the
ending doesn't explain half the shit
that happens in the movie like why that
why in the hell is he standing in the
middle of the road we don't know is she
is she going to reminisce about some
eggs I hope that would be amazing she
just looks at the eggs unless she drives
remember those eggs they splat on the
ground like the way their dad splattered
when he hit that everyone drops things
in this movie with loud sounds oh I hate
this woman by the way the character this
character is so fucking annoying
actresses find characters horrible
well that's fucking weird
this is so stupid no one would ever do
this
it's like she's there just to make her
feel bad yeah just no social skills
whatsoever I heard your husband die just
for let you know that not a day will go
by without you missing you it was so
gruesome the way that Honda hit him in
front of that dumpster I feel like every
door
it was so gruesome she kind of reminds
Iran sent me a picture of his dead body
so I knew what it looked like you guys
came I she kind of reminded me of like
Kathy Bates a little bit I can see that
yeah oh my god she just disappeared the
disappearing older lady yeah
disappearing creepy old enemies he had
his fingers and she's gone that's what
actually happened yeah perfectly
balanced unprejudiced
you know what else I hate about this
movie what's that gross it's so fucking
gray it does look like one of those
preset filters that you go into some
editing software and just click the
cinema mode and that's what you get the
colors don't pop it's just dull looking
it's a poor mishmash of colors this is
the scary color grading Chris this no no
this is the go to bed color grading this
is the this is the Netflix movie color
grading according to IMDB the budget for
this is $100,000
Wow that is actually really low I mean
really low sure for a feature so I mean
really it's just shots of people that
went to the store and now they're in a
house nothing else happens or it was a
person in the road don't forget oh yeah
yeah they cost $7 to put him there yeah
yeah the overalls were $12 and of course
you know like you said he waited there
all night no this is just one of the
directors houses looking shot little the
weekend you guys gonna make a movie yeah
we got a gaffer and a cinematographer
and we got a sound guys through it yeah
million dollar house but it has a roadie
rutile dial dial phone rotary phone yeah
yeah cuz rotary phones are scary it does
it is it is scarier I hope they have a
VHS player too yeah they start listening
to a record and it starts screeching and
playing others don't wing through the
tulips does this kid have a phone or a
Gameboy what what game fucking do it
this time my god he's got one of those
little handheld devices filled with
water and little rings that you press
the buttons and it blows
there and then you try to get the rings
to follow on the remember that I don't
even know what you're talking a little
like hand held things filled with water
and ring do you get press buttons and it
shot up I remember I know the Bobbitt
thing where you have to bop it or pull
it that's more 19 yeah maybe he has an
etch-a-sketch that is yes I do remember
that yeah maybe he has a mr. spell from
Toy Story Thank You mr. spell you're
welcome
this movie is really trying to set up
the anticipation for something that I
feel like is never going to happen
that's a perfect description for this
movie they're just it's a bunch of
build-up to nothing it's like the most
forced suspense I've ever felt in a
movie it's just there they got a hold of
a nice-looking house they over lit it
and they had him walk around and that's
most of the film and I can't wait for
you to experience it I feel like he's
gonna walk around for another 9 minutes
in this movie it's gonna feel like
that's walking I hope he goes to the
he's gonna open up the basement door and
look down it's gonna have that scary
shot from the bottom looking up you're
probably exactly what happened oh please
I'm kidding give me the give me this
cliche I need this it's great because
you have not seen this room no I have
not seen this yeah this is just my
hypothesis of course the flashlight
doesn't always work right you know
here's what I hate about this okay
okay the way this is set up like
technically I get it like they're
showing you the house but they're
showing it to you like it's something
special it just looks like a more
wealthy person's house yeah it looks
like there's a kitchen there's a stove
here's the basement Wow who fucking
cares yeah it just looks like a suburban
house nothing's happening the house and
home alone was scarier than this it was
Oh cover the furnace fucking talked the
crud the cars are still here they didn't
go to the airport Uncle Frank is this a
joke leave this guy had some
micromachines he wouldn't die doesn't
this feel like a youtube skit that you
would make before like a horror film
yeah you have no time money and you just
slap it together yeah but this is a
feature-length film mm-hmm
I mean this so far the sequence has been
like three to four minutes long and it's
it's just him walking around and he's
not discovering anything the filmmakers
are just showing us that there's a lot
of like stuff in the house and right now
he's fucking terrified and nothing
happened why did they build the basement
with fucking tunnels like this like it's
Alcatraz I don't know I really don't man
does I don't know I wonder if the tunnel
at all any point comes into play I mean
yeah but like but it's just because
somebody gets a shit chased like the
only thing that happened in that whole
scene was he fucking looked at it the
tunnel and then he broke ass tear a
house like that would never have a
basement like that okay the basement in
this house would have been drywalled
with a pool table yeah and would have
had one of those big projector TVs from
2001 yeah probably not a cave system the
cave yeah like I understand massive
Wayne that your your your father used to
walk in the Underground Railroad
I rode no I kept picturing my dead dad
outside the gas because you know my dad
died by a Honda Civic that I'm doing my
hatchback hatchback killed my thought I
was just thinking about how mad I am at
the people who killed my dad but doesn't
really matter cuz that's not part of the
story yeah we won't ever mention it
couldn't be a drunk driver it could be
anything as far as we know it was it was
the uber driver maybe that's who is
haunting the house is the uber driver
who killed the father - one big ploy to
ruin this families
you're probably right that's what it is
could be anything might as well just
make guesses these that would have felt
like cohesive granite countertops that
could be very terrifying to some people
really good I like my quartz my name is
John Flickinger does this house have
quartz in it I won't live there fuck
your house oak cabinets stainless steel
appliances okay so here's our first he
heard a sound sequence Oh first of many
great I can't wait this repetitive mess
I heard a noise interior house night
Young Logan hears a noise and wakes up
it's the hatchback who killed father who
killed from the village father
[Laughter]
are they real with this that was it look
how lit it is it does look very over lit
there's like nine softbox lights it's
hanging up up above the door car outside
honks drives away dumb kid walks up
walks back in goes to bed dumb kid walks
out that's the title of dumb kid dumb
kid walks around the movie
I'm waiting for the jump-scare I don't
even remember if there is one I think
they're sure they're setting one out
okay give me something here
they're definitely setting one up fake
deer yeah there it is
well it's not it's an open house by
Kathy Bates just run through the woods
by crazy old lady hodge again the worst
fucking idea for a jump-scare someone's
behind him and we whip to him Jesus
ninja styled stealth walked up tiptoed
right behind that crazy old woman with
her with her plan to scare an apostle
lady old crazy tiptoeing through the
woods what are you doing here hey mom
I'm gonna look at you while you sleep
how fucking creepy is this I want to
know if crazy lady just randomly pops up
again and again through she does she
shows up yes she shows up at some random
parts there's a hilarious part with her
at the end I wonder if one of these
papers say eviction notice on it
it probably says like how to get rid of
my son clearly it's not gonna say health
or like death insurance because they had
to leave their house yeah I'll stay in
some house for sale now she's looking
for like somebody to adopt him she wants
to get rid of him
really no honestly I could believe that
I'm getting or somehow the reason I'm
just thinking of like the worst family
drama I'm just thinking how to make the
movie look a Lifetime movie yeah how to
make it like something else is happening
except like what what the fuck was that
about oh my god I forgot about that
was Ed just I was watching him sleep
cheese's Christ can I just tell you once
again that's what this whole movie is
like oh right nothing happens over and
over and over false jump scares over and
over and over noises over and over and
then an ending that means nothing and
Edie who wants to play tickle sticks
yeah like who is the who is Edie
dude he he so he works with the real
estate people I guess son of a bitch I
mean those are some scary brochures well
this movie the true horror of this movie
is the domestic life of suburbia no
those are the worst chocolate-chip
cookies I've ever seen that's really
that the metaphor here John is how
frightening it is to live in suburbia
yeah this actually isn't suburbia though
it's in the middle of the mountains or
whatever yeah yeah yeah but like that's
what it's about it's the horror of
living like a wealthy family yeah
upper-class citizens have a heart as
well that is they all live in really
overlit houses that have strange people
in the basement this shot right here
it's just mr. combat boots he's the
killer
how does he have money have a job if he
do the kid your kid for Christ's sakes I
think I just said it's a birthday money
what do you say I don't know I can't
rewind it but like what the fuck did he
say anima how does he have money
birthday money yeah every day money
saved the ten dollars from his ninth
birthday it's just in his pocket it's
just crisp just ready to pay for the
sale so they really don't have any money
at all no no so this this one guy their
husband was like the only thing that
gave them anything they had no money for
themselves no savings of any insurance
they couldn't sell the vehicles I was
like their life was pretty shitty before
he died yeah yeah but they had some
really nice plants in their backyard
than they're getting in the movie Church
makes me question you know you don't
poor people don't have a ficus at least
that's the tagline for the film the
title dumb kid walks around the tag line
poor people don't have a ficus I have a
question for you Chris ask away
so you've viewed this movie before I
have
what made you click play originally on
this movie it was on Netflix it was
before bed I was lying there I wanted to
see if it was quite as bad as I had
heard and it was I I envied irritability
because I would have made it through
about 14 seconds of this before shutting
it off I would never watch this like in
the prime of the day okay when I could
be doing something else
spending time with a friend or my wife
he would like in the middle of the night
before bed I have nothing better to do
except lay there and put on some put
something on Netflix sure but here we
are in the prime of the day friends
watching this movie for the purpose of
reviewing it hating a video about yes
and making
funny piece of conch it on it why not so
how far are we in okay so we're you know
we're about I can't actually see how far
we have it seems like we're about 25
minutes to a half an hour yeah yeah yeah
this seems I wish we were a lot further
but we're 28 minutes okay and what the
fuck has happened so far dude this is
coming up to the second act and
nothing's happened
he used a flashlight and the crazy old
lady was outside there was a guy
standing in the road now they're at a
fucking clothes store if if they don't
have any money
why are they shopping for shoes she
couldn't even pay for some fucking eggs
yeah she couldn't buy eggs but she's
gonna buy a muumuu hey man I don't like
you cuz you're a man and I protect my
mom from men cuz cuz I'm a boy maybe she
should apply for a job yeah really
why don't you get a job please I hope
creepy ladies outside the car for no
reason
now they're gonna talk about how she
can't look at men so she was a trash she
was flirting wow you were flirting mom I
didn't pick up on that at all and your
son you know how to flirt with other men
with the clerk that's half your age mom
needs some lovin - the son has got a
little bit of the mommy issue thing
right fuck it's called
yeah yeah out of his complex is out of
Freudian yeah you're I think that that
sounds right
yeah well he likes to watch his mom
sleep you're gonna say standing over her
at bed monks to other things like keep
in mind the purpose of that scene of him
in that room was to grab the photo okay
yeah that's why he was there but why did
he go in he wanted to get some of her
underwear so he could wear it yeah right
now he's what that's what this maybe
should have been about he's putting it
he's got it on right now that's at the
end of the film he just he's like it
turns out that he's a oh my god fuck me
man he had another jump why was this guy
just don't give in the movie to create
jump scares he just runs around shaky
and shit I did some speed before I came
over guys I'm gonna go yeah take care
I'm I'm I'm just gonna run away I didn't
have a car here I just I ran down the
mountainside
don't you think they would have noticed
the car I don't think he has one he just
ran up there yeah he's just ran through
the woods but anyway about what we were
saying the kid was just walking into the
mom's room for what reason to look at
her while she is sleeping I mean she's a
nice-looking mom you know it's weird
can't blame him it's weird dad died he's
got you know he's weird there's some
psychological issues here okay yeah I'll
buy it that seat would that not have
made a better movie the kid loses his
mind of course of course and where's his
mom's underwear third act is him just
running around and his mom's clothes
like screaming he's all sweaty his eyes
are bulging out he's holding an act that
turns into home alone home alone yeah he
sets up traps for for his mom there's
paint cans right there both stares yeah
yeah that will protect you he just
looked under his bed he was checking for
that crazy guy to make sure there was no
drugs under there is that a phone he
finally has a phone wow he's got a phone
what was that the entire movie
this is legitimately like one of the
most boring modern horror films ever
made it's just people living their life
with bad cinematography just enough
people I say this pisses me off to be
honest dude okay the fact that it's made
and released I'm like yeah there are so
many people who have ideas we could make
a better film than this look at this
fucking shot Chris it's still going I
know no one's in frame
there's the door opened a little bit in
the background that's what happened this
is big moments like the cinematography
of what a webcam would capture it just
pisses me off you know how did this get
financed how is there someone in it that
that is known like Dylan Manette how
nothing who read this and said this is a
good idea
Netflix must be desperate for any form
of conduit I guarantee that this this
probably wasn't made it was like made
and then Netflix bought it possibly like
it probably wasn't like hey Netflix
we're gonna give you money yeah that
that could be I I don't know he isn't a
Netflix TV series yes I wonder if there
was some I feel like he had a like a
leftover budget of a hundred grand and
they said let's make a junk movie that
twelve-year-old teenage girls will watch
and maybe be terrified of I don't know
all right
just all right is that the mom yes
does he come in there and watch her be
so funny would you like me to wash your
back Mommy Dearest
Oh see John that's the hidden subtext
that that most people just don't
understand
that's the deeper meaning here bowl of
cereal corn would he take his phone oh
man this whole fucking movie dude is
about some guy in their house just kind
fucking around with them yeah Anna moves
the phone he's kind of just a prankster
he's a glorified prankster he's about to
do it again right here yeah
does he take her soap no paper towel no
he fucks with the water pressure oh so
he is the plumber he could be the
plumber he's a plumber he does fucking
come in well he's wishing that there was
a mirror right there so yeah there
probably is a mirror right there he's
gonna go in his room and oh my god I
mean that's like she was a good-looking
mom see wearing shoes in the house socks
he's wearing socks okay it's just like
one thing this movie got right it sucks
autumn listen to the music how it builds
it up my cereal
that can I be rare with you man yeah
this is about the level of invention
that I had when I was a 15 year old
making a horror movie by myself with
just me and a tripod correct yeah I am
sounds over there the bowls over there
sounds over here
and then that's that's that's it now we
went over again lick the carpet the
music builds it up so much too he just
wants to look at his mom that is really
that is what this movie valley does
it's probably those old pipes in this
brand-new house and right another shot
of the basement question never mind I
was I was gonna question maybe she
probably would have gotten dressed by
this point or I do feel like that
walk-around and the house said it was
cold like you said the water got
freezing I'd be like I'd be getting
dressed
does this basement not have lights for
no apparent reason whatsoever see this
is an open house and then they just
thought you know what we don't really
want to sell it yeah so we'll just not
install lights in the base but we won't
finish the basement we'll just leave
paint cans down there and all kinds of
creepy weird shit yeah wobb wobb I was
still applying so it was like wow I mean
like it's just building this shit up so
much when nothing there's nothing okay
this is a good tutorial video on how to
light a pilot light on your water what
it is yeah yeah I mean you're waiting
for the inevitable like shadow behind
her or noise or something and it's you
know like they've they framed this shot
expecting us to to wait for the guy
who's gonna appear behind her and that's
that's all it is
over and over again but we don't even
get that that cheap pale but then we cut
we constantly they're cutting to like
the kitchen as they dolly towards the
door like yes something like he's
upstairs rather than downstairs like
they're building the suspense or
something it's just constant over and
over again this kind of shit if this was
like little scenes here and there that
kind of built to something that's
fantastic that's you you build tension
that leads to something but it doesn't
lead to anything no they completely just
ruined their entire setup and kill the
momentum and the suspense that they had
why is everyone looking under that
little-ass bed because it's alright
the plumbers hiding under the bed it was
the plumber under the bed under again
and we cut to the next day and it's it's
set noises and that's this whole fucking
movie dude him running which equals
nothing whatsoever just no payoff no
doesn't make any sense
now they just had to give his character
something besides boy who walks around
yeah
little Norman Bates
[Laughter]
like I talked in my that video I made a
few years back the problem with horror
movies today yeah
I said horror movies should be like sex
or like you're building to something and
then you get a release and you don't
want that release to happen too early
and you don't want it to happen too late
but this movie is nothing but building
this movie is like sex with yourself
when you're 12 years old it's it's rapid
youth areand you're in the bathroom
before your mom knocks on the door you
just want to pop one out yeah but this
movie is all build there's no release
yes constantly over and over again yeah
yes it's repetitive why is he there why
does it look bad you're just a guy is
that the clerk yeah it is and he's
pissed again because the guy is talking
to to his mom I mean I'm not gonna lie
if I was a dude in a small town and some
hot mom walked in I might look into it a
little bit yeah clearly she was flirting
with him I mean he really does have a
shitty excuse hey I work at make seven
dollars an hour at a retail store but
I'm here to buy this million-dollar
mansion I seen it I sent a sign for sale
I'm the clerk at a clothing store by the
way like everyone who comes here I just
randomly walked up the mountainside to
get here the guy who killed their dad
fucking drew
there they're constantly surprised by
people like at their door when they're
driving up to their house and it's a
house that's for sale there's no car
yeah yeah now do you think the mom is
genuinely lonely and interested in this
guy um I feel like it's probably too
soon but that she's she's probably
depressed and just like Oh somebody to
talk to you do you say after like a
tragedy you know yeah yeah I shot for
some human affection yeah I wouldn't
blame her she'll every right tell them
that he's every right died he's dead the
best scene would have been if the mom
and that dude hook up and Logan walks
into the room and sees it and he's like
yeah and then he gets angry and killed
do you think they use the same shot over
and over like they had like a kitchen
shot yeah this yeah panning kitchen show
here's what I think they did I think
they installed they laid down the dolly
track yep and they put the camera on it
and then they just had the actors come
in and out of the scene to do it over
and over again 15 times how many times
in the script are they in the kitchen
okay six times alright we'll do them all
right now now what is he well she asked
to go explore the basement or is he just
curious to wonder around the house and
why are we assuming in on this kid as he
listens to this music and he thinks
about his dad please show clip with the
dad dying oh yes something more oh I
need more than that
I want to see that so I want to see that
dummy body fly through the yeah so much
for a gruesome death Oh your hand bled
band-aid would have corrected that he's
still in my house I'm the man of the
house they don't find that out some
random guy just walking around their
house right now well it's not their
house it's the open house usually when
people come to look at a house for sale
they bring a realtor and they don't have
an open house though oh yeah it's just a
constant open house well no it's it
there's times a day when it's open yeah
okay he said he missed the one time or
whatever yeah yeah so they're letting
him because he was nice at the at the
clothing store also I think the only
reason that other people are in this
movie is just to make you have other
options for who the killer might be just
forcefully put into the story yeah like
maybe it's the clothing store clerk
maybe it's the old lady random yeah the
kook you the kooky old lady the kooky
next-door neighbor yeah but that's all
it is it's like you can actually like
see them writing the script and they're
like we need to have more characters so
that there's there's more options see
they ruined all this because right in
the beginning soon as they pulled up
these we saw creepy
heavyset guy handle the road we know
it's not the woman we know it's not the
guy it's you know it's a guy with that
wears combat boots right to an open
house mm-hmm
so if okay I can't wait to know what
he's looking at oh nothing okay they
couldn't put like a dead bird they could
nothing just fucking trees fuck my life
fuck everything fuck you and your
noodles Logan look the boiling water
splashes and your face fuck you and your
hot dogs this movie it's just so boring
you're always paranoid buy that damn
doorbell someone rang the doorbell fuck
it is very uncourteous to come look at
an open house at night oh this lady
it's like she looks a little house this
10,000 square-foot house
you
uh I would never eat banana bread an old
lady like that I would throw it out you
just know she doesn't wash her hands now
next time bring a fucking jello mold on
the doorstep
because you did you crazy old hag all
right well she's insane mm-hmm
she's made some banana bread but she's
still less creepy than Logan yeah oh
great there's mom in the shower
yeah you think these it was written by a
man and woman you think like he wrote
these scenes I don't know you know I
don't this is an empowering you know I
guess oh yeah yeah definitely so the
killer just likes to play a little
practical jokes that's the whole fucking
movie dude I'm gonna make the water cold
it's the whole movie man I'm not kidding
uh
I'm gonna hide the toilet paper it's the
same shot too did the one guy everyone
is the same shot it's just the lighting
is different that's the same shit over
and over again do they find the body of
the one guy who went down into the
basement earlier in the day that no one
cared to even ask about again I don't
remember I don't remember she showers
this entire fucking movie doesn't she
she showers he walks through hallways he
looks at things that aren't there and
gets creeped out by nothing and the bad
guy pulls pranks now do you think she
uses conditioner if she did the bad guy
would replace it yes with shampoo yes
and then and then take her conditioner
okay good that's what would happen yes
I want Logan to walk in again peppy so
funny with a bowl cereal just watches
mom showers and eats Captain Crunch and
crunch so if the killer is indeed hiding
in this house this reminds me of a movie
from the early 90s starring Gary Busey
where he legit hides in the Attic of a
house and creeps on this family what
movie is this I don't remember the name
but that would be a good one to watch
Chris there's a few movies like I think
it's called a man in the attic or black
Christmas yeah is about something
similar the original black Christmas
well this one has Gary Busey and I don't
think there's any topping that and it
takes itself serious it's like eyes in
the attic or something it's I think it
only exists on VHS - but I remember
watching it years ago my dad recorded
all these shitty movies on beta tape I
think it was my first Gary Busey
experience and I'll never forget it I
always thought he was an erotic first
Gary Busey experience is never to be
from having your attic I got your
Christmas orders up on my butt that's
fucking hilarious see that's what this
movie needs Gary Busey foot here is
ornament that is but yeah yeah I agree
there's no be cool
he's thinking about his mom right now oh
man where's this hand I don't want it
yeah yeah yeah this movie could be a
psychological thriller it really could
ask tweaked it it could be so much more
no the killer took his glasses was it
called Haider in the house yes
yeah Gary Busey hide her in the house I
just found it on IMDB yeah we we should
get together and watch that all right
I'm putting on my watch okay oh cool
it's on prime its own problems two bucks
to rent I should say that's gonna be the
best two dollars we ever spend yeah it's
two bucks we'll split it all right yeah
I'll pay a dollar you pay yeah I really
don't you just want to watch that based
on the concept along idea yeah I'm so so
oh my god I'm so glad I can hear him
peeing and while he pees
it's only another guy walked on good
sound effects I was talking about the
the piss splashing in the toilet yeah
that'd be funny if you just it'd be
scarier if he came over and just kind of
like listened to him peeing is that just
walking by I wonder why he didn't wash
his hands because he's he's a gross boy
the killer hid the soap oh that's a good
thing they backlit that seriously see
dude we are now halfway through this
movie and look we have built to the
scariest thing that happens is guy
watching him take a pee pee yeah okay I
can't believe we're only halfway through
this movie I'm just saying though like
seriously though like from a writing
perspective don't you think someone said
hey something else should happen no they
said let's make this little asshole run
again it's maddening
there's just no character development or
any reason for anything happening right
now no there's none wait that's it
that's all you got supposed to be a
runner he's bothered because I'm a
plumber watched him in bed all night or
somebody does she's just lady hide in
the woods waiting dude everyone in this
movie teleports to wherever the scenes
happening randomly on a curried country
back road if they need him for the scene
they appear there how'd you get here the
script sent me oh she took a stroll
through the forest that's how she starts
her day that's how she ends her days as
well because she randomly shows up in
front of your door with banana bread I
think she just lives in a tree actually
she I think she just hides out inside a
tree oh you know who she reminds me of
the the fucking the pigeon lady from
home alone - oh yeah yeah bird and bird
shit yeah yeah so disgusting sick wow if
she was she showed up in the scene - do
you think Logan gives her some turtle
doves at the end of the movie I can have
two well two turtle doves you keep one
and you give the other one to someone
very special midnight tonight we're
gonna rob Duncan's toy chest
[Laughter]
great plan Harry
she came by again to remind them about
how shitty their lives are and yeah she
left hi your dad died a gruesome death
take care now bye bye maybe she's
married to the killer yeah could be
and they're both just psychopaths and
that but but I'm I'm sure the movie
never even hints at that probably not oh
that's the killer to me I'm probably if
we were playing clue that would be my
guess the honest truth though is it
doesn't fucking matter because the movie
doesn't give you a reason to give a shit
the honest fuckin truth is I want that
guy right there to go bash everyone's
head in with a pipe wrench right now
yeah Wow
she's doing your dishes wah wah ooh
macaroni and cheese yeah sounds good
right now I'm hungry I'm hungry too
smoothie made me hungry let's go eat a
big bowl of cereal yes we watch our
mom's shower the that's probably him
that's the that's exactly yeah yeah
actually I'm her husband and we just got
a folk with evil cuz you know we were
already able to do
oh he's trying to he's brought make the
kid look like he's a little sociopath
yeah he's just pulling a prank again
he's pranking does this maybe we should
just be called prankster prankster you
know what the worst part of this whole
movie is it's hard to pick one but what
is that's not it's not the bland
cinematography it's not it's not the
fact that there's no story it's the fact
that it takes itself so goddamn
seriously yeah it really does yeah it's
a movie about a mom and a Ben and her
son and there's HAP there's noises in
the night this should be a fun popcorn
throw away silly movie and it's like so
fucking deathly serious it's depressing
it is and the thing is they stop right
before they get hamming up enough to be
entertaining and it's embarrassing
because these actors are way better than
this material well you know everyone
needs a paycheck but this couldn't have
been a big paycheck they just they just
I'm just saying like these actors are
way better than this and and like these
filmmakers don't even deserve these
actors they don't like they would be
great in a great movie they don't
deserve the cameras they shot the movie
I know they know I was hoping I wanted
you mom it's just one full cereal I just
want a bowl of cereal you never give me
cereal anymore
that would make me cereal yeah
yeah your dad was a fucking homeless man
their dad was too stupid to move out of
the way of a speeding car in a parking
lot yeah and he had like he literally
left them with nothing you're all stupid
that's why they're in this but they
really are the biggest dumb family that
ever existed the mom had no savings of
any kind not nothing they had no they
clearly they didn't seem to have a will
he didn't seem to have anything left
over I mean they're not they're clearly
like at least 40 now they're renting the
house at least four dishes renting her
house now this fiscal responsibility is
lacking it was common sense look he woke
up
he's walking again he's walking around
the house around the house that's not
scary at all no it really isn't it's
because they don't know what a nice
cabin I'd like to go stay out I mean
look at like a movie like insidious yes
like or you know like even that found
the budget was only like a million or
something yeah which granted is more
than a hundred thousand but like
seriously like it's so much easier it's
so easy to make a house look creepy and
a lot of it has to do with what the
house is yeah cabinets or is a
nice-looking house it really is they
should have shot in a different location
at finally the family should have been
forced to suffer a little bit more than
staying imagine yeah like like what if
what if the open house was like a house
that was having a really hard time
selling that's why they get to go stay
there yeah that would make sense like no
one wants to buy it because shit's
broken in it or maybe it's just it's old
and they just needed a place to crash
for a while like there's just so many
little tiny changes that if someone had
just given these guys notes on their
script the little tiny changes like that
they're gonna just made the movie a
little bit better this this movie almost
feels like it didn't have a script
[Laughter]
his eyes disturb bleeding his eyes and
his mouth bleed
I like how every body in this one was
just there when he wakes up I know like
how does this kid get any sleep yeah
just sorry we're always gonna be
staining every time I go to bed if I was
this kid I'd be thinking when will
someone stand over me at some point in
my slumber yeah where does creepy
real-estate guy running around yeah he's
just in the movie to be like another
possible killer does a mom take another
shower or I don't remember but yeah the
movie really does feel like a first
draft or something
like nobody gave him notes they never
showed it to anybody and yet somehow it
got made it's really just the same thing
happening over and over again yeah it it
has walk around the house creepy loud
sound weird neighbor repeat mm-hmm it's
kind of mind-boggling actually I just
feel like anybody would be like hey this
is not that great yeah but it still got
financed and shot and yeah but like and
they ones and movies like that get shot
you know and they end up like on DVD at
Walmart or something like you know
whatever ghost house ate but like this
seems like an actual attempt to finance
something and it's just it's I don't get
it man why they keep writing it into the
same people to people in this entire
town that's there's two people in this
town that exist well see Jon everyone in
the movie is only there because the
script wrote them there oh that's right
yeah there isn't like actually a
bustling - oh by the way here's this
fucking dolly shot here's another dolly
shot of living towards the door oak wood
door Janet everyone in this town is only
there because there's no other people
you know when they went to the clothing
store there was just a clerk you know
it's just that
everyone else carry what's scary oh boy
it is not Jesus
cherrywood scary and yeah there's there
was nobody here there's cars in the park
there's a car there's a car fuck there's
a car that's but that's the plumber look
at him I was thinking I just walk home I
got a call from the realtor the house is
broken into but the cops just aren't
involved whatsoever right oh wow I was
expecting maybe a cop to be there okay
that would be too easy
it's two bowls of cereal please bless
this wonderful bowl of macaroni and
cheese just for me see how many home
alone references we should have been
gold yeah we'll come back around nine
o'clock that way it stopped in because
kids are scared the door yep you're
afraid of the dark mom
yeah Fran the dark tomorrow you know
yeah no I'm not so this dude set up all
the cops wow this dude set up the
fucking music and like a dinner and then
he called them and then didn't say
anything
yeah he's like he underlined he's like
[Applause]
is your fridge running better stop it is
this Domino's Pizza I'd like two pizzas
this now does the kid get mad at the mom
for talking to the cops in a jealous
rage oh my god I wish you're flirting
with them
now that guy doesn't look like he be a
cop know him no he looks like he'd be a
model for like Macy's he looks like it
looks like what's-his-name who wrote
those movies uh American something you
max landis yeah kind of like max max
landis yeah he does I was thinking he
looked like that one actor Milo
Vee something from Rocky Balboa Rocky's
son yeah he does I could see that too
but with a shittier haircut yeah
the haircut from 1997 wearing j.crew
t-shirts those are like the most like
throwaway horror thriller cops we're
like there's obviously some weird
fucked-up shit happen here and they're
like yeah we can't do anything by
what do you mean there's nothing to
worry about did we can't afford what
can't afford we can't at least we get
tection you can't afford to stay in the
house where we're going to get raped and
murdered because they she's like honey
just don't worry about it okay someone
played Christmas music made a special
dinner table for us and then called us
and said nothing but it's fine okay
yeah worry about it no big deal yeah
that's Mark Wahlberg it's fine okay -
wait okay just just fuck off this Bob's
explore the secure Shima it's like he or
she went I'm gonna take this for her Pam
I slammed on my wrist we're not stealing
ice cream cones it's not birthday cake
okay they don't get a birthday cake
satyam oh it's macaroni cheese go take a
shower hey you a question you ever hear
about the bees here you survived so many
bees have been disappearing around the
world taking interest in science sorry
let's hear some theories about why this
might be happy
we know how your father died a gruesome
death his head were through the
windshield
do you know what that's like when you
drop eggs on the floor no no I'm not
alright mom cuz I'm attracted to you and
you don't notice me gosh yes I've been
trying to do this all day mom ask me
this all of my life please tell me that
you sleep in the bed together I got
remember I need this I need this more
than anything in my life
I want the shot of them in the bed think
I do I forget there are some undertones
here wow he's so jealous of his mom's
interactions with other men oh my god
I'm gonna take this I'm gonna put it in
my butt I need to brush my teeth and
throw out this number because you can't
ever be with anyone else except me like
he said he's going to brush his teeth
but mom's brushing her - yeah
that's interesting my god the doorbell
it's such a fucking like thing they
constantly oh my god the doorbell I want
to know who it is I'm so interested I
don't even remember it's hard to
remember when like the whole movie is
just a series of them running into
various it's just people walking around
their house of knowing fucking neighbors
that's what this movie is that's it
that's all it is
mm-hmm ah who's names Chris didn't even
notice Oh cold him for what it's okay oh
so we could have a threesome yeah hey
can I can i watch you guys I like to
watch like the room yeah Danny it's like
to watch you guys yeah that's weird
Danny ha ha ha see Danny sometimes
people like to have a long time you know
[Laughter]
yeah ChIP chip chip chip dude don't
touch me motherfucker this show my ass
hos made it show my ass so they're just
randomly walking around in the very
well-lit backyard to flashlights he got
his mom oddly looks through the window
he got the clothing store clerks number
and was like hey man you want to come
over and kind of like sneak around and
look it around because I'm nervous you
know also my mom is lonely so maybe you
guys could have sex or something she
does look like she needs some
fulfillment
I mean clearly there she was interested
in a guy and then this son's like no no
you are only for me
they're my mother I came out of you and
I'm going back in
[Laughter]
wait is this guy sleeping on the fucking
couch now yeah I think they said it was
like since it's late and you came over
or you can sleep on the couch
this is like this setup to a porn on I
know like brazzers I'll be here a lot
more because your mom kind of lexa me
yeah I'm just I'm just randomly staying
at these people's house that I met in a
store
that house has 15 bedrooms but he sits
out on my couch yeah right here really
anytime where there's two beds in that
house he's like he's on the computer
again I mean god this fucking movie dude
would have been so much funnier of him
and that Chris guy were sleeping in the
same bed I gather right I'll look
another contact scene just this whole
movie is the same shit give me the
close-up it was the lover II don't know
he's gonna hear a noise John God I mean
that's just Chris sneaking upstairs
though yeah aiding his mom yeah yeah
that's where he is right now
mmm goes in the basement and they're
making passionate erotic love when
people say Chris in a movie when they're
looking for someone like what just
happened yeah I sometimes ago what what
it doesn't happen that much Chris is not
a common name in movies no I guess
you're right yeah what what I just can't
wait for this explanation I can't wait
or lack thereof yeah you're not gonna be
happy got a score it's annoying
what what what
well something happened
Wawa want me to do it every time mom I'm
wrong so did Chris try to get in the car
get his throat slit because throw a slit
in place in the car oh I don't know man
don't wander wah wah wah
and that was this water or gasoline it's
water okay just needed a please try to
make them freeze to death I guess really
because it's like winter outside
wow that's his plan hyperthermia I'll
slit this guy's throat but this guy I'm
this kid splash some water on him yeah
and he might remember this scene dude
okay I remember laying in bed right now
okay
and I remember falling like halfway
falling asleep because this the scare
you know yeah
in this scene takes so fucking long I
actually started to doze off all right
let's so here he comes he's just gonna
eat like tonight's the night I guess and
get some bed and cuddles er and I'm
gonna kill this one dude and then I'm
gonna make the Sun freeze to death
because I'm tired of taking a cereal
[Laughter]
Justin plays in bed folds his hand he
like folds his fingers together oh wait
I just want to know how this plays out
right here it takes forever right now
he's thinking damn most open sheet
notice me yeah I laid in bed next door
for nothing I wish needed to hurry up
and just kill this family so the movie's
runtime would be shorter really he's
still there see what I mean like I
fucking fell asleep for like a minute
yeah nothing happens like a minute I
remember I remember seeing him getting
bed it was like oh what's gonna happen
and I fucking fell asleep there really
stretching out the runtime of this movie
they don't have anything else man it's
just people on a house there's nothing
here yeah it's just seems monotonous
scene he's still in the bed and nothing
has happened maybe he fell asleep
he killed Chris he killed him and now
he's to fall asleep you see what I mean
it's still hit like it's still he's late
now she's looking at photos there's a
little Polaroids
those are some nice trees her looking at
those pictures of trees is like us
watching this movie get pictures of
trees his pranks are getting really
intense now other sleeping pictures
mm-hmm
it just rack focus to like whatever that
fuzzy thing is on her bit on our table I
yeah just like directed by into this
piece of shit I hey I wouldn't expect
anything else
I can't I so want to be at least have to
duct tape their mouths to that's it that
just goes with it mm-hmm
is this movie an hour and a half I think
so okay yeah okay we have we have 12
minutes left just counting down the
seconds we have 12 more minutes oh how
are you the real bad man tonight I'm a
man of my word starts breaking her
fingers yeah just this little piggy went
to the market little snappy snap snap
why he just laying out there cold like
just this guy this legitimately is a
movie about a very very sadistic
prankster it really is yeah all this is
is a this is prankster the movie
I feel like they so cold
chew out boot boy he has to get naked
and lady said his mom for warmth yeah
that's what he wishes what this was all
about go and suck it up it's like
walking around after Harriet alike but
my fingers hurt what did he do to you
did he touch you did you flirt with him
[Laughter]
we're gonna get out together we're gonna
be a couple I mean I made a family again
where's Chris he's dead oh good good
good damn it I need to go downstairs
okay well because we have to be a couple
again I mean I mean you're my mom sorry
I love you mom I want to see her fingers
different angles crazy fingers he still
has ice on his his eyebrows yeah he was
only outside well we don't know how long
he was outside I guess we don't know how
long she was out cold but sure but by
this point the ice is thought off your
hair yeah yeah but maybe John maybe in
the ultimate prank he's actually turned
on the air conditioning really high in
the house oh so it's make reasoning and
that would be a good one that's a good
one
he even gave the kid a knife okay now
this knife comes into play yeah later
but like once you find out why it again
is one of those coincidences
is like him standing out on the road I
where it doesn't actually make any sense
okay maybe he was trying to make the kid
look like a a serial killer or setting
him up or framing Emerson yeah because a
cop walks in right now and just sees him
all jittery and shaky shoot that kid the
mom would probably be happier to she
just wanted to hook up with Chris I just
want to deal with this kid shit her hey
she didn't love her husband either oh my
gosh was she ever once upset about the
death of her husband ever once did you
get that no the film glosses over
everything she was more upset about the
financial situation loss of her husband
yes he was ready to go yeah she's a
woman in her she's she's ready she wants
to go I'll explore other opportunities
she was pinned up mm-hmm I know one when
I see one even now it's still a movie
about him just walking around his house
but he's he's a popsicle now now he's a
popsicle he's so cold he's still cold
here's an idea
dumbass close the front door here's an
idea put a jacket on let's dolly through
the hallway huh how many random shots
can we show if somebody running through
this big house that's not scary and it
length down the stairs slowly cuz a
second ago he went up pretty fast this
is called suspense Chris oh yeah I
forgot so you make a whore bill I forgot
yeah he's I swear more ice has been
added to his hair yeah he looks a little
bit more like mr. freeze than before I
used to see
chill chill out kid it's just a bowl of
cereal bird boy or boy
I've never wanted to watch someone die
more than ever like I just Logan I want
to see him die brutally you got our wait
for it oh it's this the it's coming up
like the whole I need it now
that's something was about to happen
that's so fucking stupid
you don't put an HVAC system away from a
water heater you put him beside each
other oh look at that
yeah knowledge from John movie mistake
movie sucks Logan we were just run into
this knife like what is the purpose of
that John why why did she run at him why
was she there why is he holding the
knife why did she run into the knife
there's it's like this is what I'm
saying it's like the killer gave that
knife there knowing that he would take
it and then stab his mom somehow yeah
but what okay what but that's this movie
dude it's like random coincidences they
make it's already in place yeah yeah
look yeah yeah I get that he's really
cold but like he's supposed to be a
great runner but all that movement you
would warm up by now right
I want I want your contact lens what I
forgot about this what good thing he was
just left his eyes open for him to do
that
really how gentle to say now run yeah
he's like okay I'm gonna do it come on
shake man kids got the shakes let me
just run deeper into the woods
God what a dumb movie well I mean we
knew that an hour and 20 I mean God act
that you made me watch this Chris as
well video to make its uh oh yeah I
forgot we are making a video about this
gosh just fucking die and you should die
Tom and you should die I just killed my
mom hurts your love of my life yeah your
fault your dad died it's your fault your
mom's dead it's not you deserve to die
cold and alone under a log oh this is my
favorite part of the whole movie right
here you ready I can't you ready I'm
ready the pigeon lady shows up yeah
[Laughter]
what shows up to look at the moon walks
away randomly that's it right in the
middle of the woods she likes to take
those strolls jogs she does yeah that
character was clearly defined as doing
that can you honestly look at me and
tell me that that shot was put in there
for a laugh or something it had to have
been no that no God that was serious
that was the biggest scare of the film
Chris the pivotal point I like how he's
still walking and it's like there's
roads and and places he could be right
really empty yeah I know there's a road
right yeah with this house but he's like
no I'm just gonna run through the woods
and go to some creeks good I mean I
think we've had enough scenes of random
people approaching their house without a
vehicle so clearly you can get to it
without a veers yeah exactly but this
cell they all got there that's what I'm
saying it's been a dana night in the
woods you'd get to their house randomly
oh yeah all the characters just walks
through the woods got it
this is this is a piece of shit I know
it's fucking terrible this is one of the
worst whore this is the worst film I
think I've watched in years you
understand why we have to review it you
die like a coward the biggest bitch
scream ever why the fuck are the hazards
on yeah
what yep that's it that's it John are
these upcoming victims of the plumber or
you got it yeah the this house is just
for sale still they
okay wait for it wait for it
I'm waiting Wow
worst marketing of any real estate agent
right there by the way that's a terrible
place never put a spoof number two first
John's looking not even a fucking phone
number on it this way to open house so
creepy guy drives the Bronco to another
open house to stalk a family and play
Christmas music and cook macaroni and
cheese and then eventually set up some
elaborate scheme in which they die he
breaks their fingers he breaks the
fingers forces someone to floor some
water on them yeah
kills random guy who was on couch and
then that's I am that's the open house
that disgusted me I'm now Dumber for
watching that movie it's like the happy
gilmore yeah or the Billy Madison that
was the most uninspired piece of trash
I've ever seen in my life I am angry I
everyone here is now Dumber for having
what we heard that know that that was
excusable no I know it's unexcusable I
agree
I agree I told you when I watched it how
it made me delish it Emilia upset like
one perspective of a filmmaker and the
perspective of a film watcher sure yeah
it's awful
I want to understand more I know that I
know I want to comprehend how and why I
have a grotesque like need to know how
this all happened
I yeah I don't I don't get it I'm I am
lost right now Chris I feel so empty but
I do want some cereal alright well guys
look forward to a hilarious 'ti review
of this on my channel John and I are
going to be talking about it and thank
you so much as always for listening here
on patreon we'll try to do more collab
commentaries every once in awhile and
not always for shit movies fuck you open
house yeah so nevertheless thank you
very much for watching for listening and
watching along with us
and thank you John thank you Chris this
was this was not fun but you know
nevertheless thank you very much guys
have a good one